yes Jane the uh offensive that the
ukrainians have conducted has been
described by all the analysts as
spectacular and indeed it is they've got
hold of the whole of the kharkiv region
the Russians have withdrawn this will
probably go down as the battle of the
oskill river because the ukrainians were
able to push the Russians up against the
Oscar River around kubiansk and then
push them over the river in ways that
the Russians can't do very much about
there's an old military principle goes
with all military thinking whatever unit
you're talking about whether it's a
platoon or a company or a battalion or a
division two up one back for every two
units that are engaged in battle you
need one behind them in order to
reinforce or to cover a withdrawal if
things go wrong the ukrainians have put
together certainly two equivalent
divisions two uh set to force that look
like a division one of them is involved
in uh in this area in around kharkiv and
the other one down in cursing so almost
certainly there is a third division that
they're keeping back for reinforcement
on the two up one back principle so the
question is what might they do with it
now that they've got the Russians off
balance one possibility is that they
would try to as it would get around the
back of some of these Russian forces
that took for instance severity Donetsk
the Russians spent 101 days conquering
severeign and it now looks as if some
early moves are that the ukrainians look
as if they're trying to move possibly to
the north of solar Donetsk rather than
trying to tack it across the river come
around the back of it and take it that
way that may or may not work out they
may try to actually just penetrate into
the donbass another possibility is that
the ukrainians might use their other
area their one back division in effect
to drive southwards and literally get
right to the coast maybe to marry Apollo
to Melita pole and break up this Russian
land bridge the famous land bridge that
has existed from the donbass area right
through to Crimea that would be opening
a third front in the war which would be
very dramatic but you can't bet against
the Russians the the Ukraine is not
doing that because they are now as we're
dominating the agenda for what happens
next and in Kirsten down in the
southwest uh Curson City itself is under
threat the ukrainians have not uh made
the same sort of inroads there as the
dramatic ones they made up in the uh
kharkiv region but nevertheless they're
moving around particularly Tom ya balker
is very important because if they've
taken Tommy balker and they're quite a
lot of reports that they have then
they'll get round behind the Russians
inside the city and meanwhile they're
moving in on Curson City the two big
objectives of course are cursing City
and novakovka there's Big Dam at novakov
that dams the nepra river and there's a
big hydroelectric power plant there and
that's quite important to all the
supplies some of the water and some of
the electricity that goes to Crimea this
front is not moving as fast or as
dramatically as the front up in car give
but what is happening behind the arrows
as it were is just as important and in
the north there are persistent reports
that Russian forces are running short of
ammunition and that some of them it is
said are trying to negotiate some local
surrenders that may or may not be true
but Ukrainian Southern Commander saying
it's true a lot of other people are
saying it's true we'll see there may be
some dramatic developments in the
southern front in the near future Jane
Michael thanks very much